uh other people trying to take content
uh
break in a mess with
an exfiltrate data
um in
in working on governance programs to
help those kinds of groups really
protect themselves
um
here I oversee some of our different
bootcamp programs and what we'll talk
about today is the cyber security boot
camp which I'm really excited about uh
We've started this about uh
uh three years ago with full stack
Academy which is now a part of Simply
learn and simply learn manages our
software engineering our machine
learning bootcamp and
um
and and several others so this is a is a
is a really great program uh Stuart and
I are going to talk a bit about what's
uh behind it what some of the curricula
why is this a good program for you we'll
try to understand a little bit more
about uh you all and see what is it that
you're looking for out of a kind of an
intensive uh learning program
and uh this dirt will also get into
talking about how does this program uh
work how do you enroll uh what are some
of the benefits of getting you job ready
and being out there and part of the um
uh the cover of cyber Defenders and
we'll answer any kind of questions along
the way
uh
so when we think about cyber security
you already know what the reason is that
that we need that part of our
perspective and why I think that our
program in Caltech is is different and
also how we thought about this program
when we first put it together is it's
it's not just about
um
securing uh things on the web it's also
about the the networks and the centers
but also more importantly we have to
think about critical infrastructure what
is critical infrastructure uh those are
airports Banks large places where people
can convene uh entertainment it's the
power generation plants
um
all the all these things that make
life work
um airports uh you know Transportation
uh Communications networks and and so
while there are Bad actors that
that are really just about
getting money or and ransomware and and
trying to do things like that or other
types of fraud there's bad actor there
are Bad actors they're either state or
non-state that are just out there just
to create chaos
um and and we've seen that what we've
done in in designing part of this
program is making sure that you have
access to projects uh Technologies uh
leading practices and insights from
those kinds of vulnerabilities and
threats and and how people have
recovered
um
the the program is is really about
creating uh
new skills for you uh so you can join
any kind of role and so whether you're a
developer who's looking to move into a
cyber security role or you're an analyst
you haven't been exposed to that much
coding but this is maybe important uh
for you uh you can either shift your
career or jump straight into cyber
security cult having a background and in
in coding and analytical uh tools and
processes are are going to be um
uh brought you through what uh what
we're going to do in this
in this program
in in addition to a number of analytical
skills and coding skills uh we're going
to get into really the thinking behind
uh the motivations of of Bad actors but
we're going to think analytically about
what creates vulnerabilities what
creates
um I'm just going to check out the chats
for a second
um
is just making sure uh Stewart if we're
answering those along the way
um how do we recognize what are our
leading practices for uh uh
development and protecting the things
that we have whether it's in embedded
systems or web systems or
um
Control Systems things like that so not
just uh kind of the the stuff that we
just see every day you know it's the
Building Systems the the things you
don't always see
um we'll learn about business practices
such as continuity and Recovery
um uh forensics trying to look at all
the breadcrumbs and evidence and the
facts that lead to
root cause
analysis through root cause analysis
um
and and
trying to put together all the pieces
that really kind of either let you know
something could be going wrong something
did go wrong how did it go wrong and
what is it going to take to fix that
uh
let's see just a second
uh so we've we've introduced a couple of
questions throughout this presentation
this morning and uh Stuart you want to
jump in here and these are so we can get
a better sense of
uh who you are and if this program is
going to be a right fit for you
right and to do this I'm going to need
to reclaim the host privilege oh hold on
a second if you would stop sharing your
screen for a second
see if I can do that here
and bear with us this is a new platform
for uh simply learning so I'm going to
um
in future we won't have to do the swap
but right now I'm going to launch this
poll
and the question for everyone is what is
stopping you from upskilling in this
field before now
try to do this uh
share my version of the
but we'll level this open for about
another 20 seconds
and please get your answers in I see
them coming in
if you're watching on YouTube live you
can
show you what this question is
you can put A B C or D into your um
comment or chat box
and we'll
go ahead and and look
poll here
I will share the result
so the most popular answers in in order
are you couldn't find a program with a
comprehensive curriculum cover all the
skills that Mike mentioned
you didn't feel you would get practical
experience to demonstrate your expertise
um or you had a difficult
time in finding the hours to study in
your schedule so
with that I'm going to
let Mike take it back
almost ready
and you should be able to resume
okay
guys seeing this yeah I'm just a second
okay that works yeah we're on the air
okay so what
[Music]
um
what's great about the the questions and
thank you for for taking time to answer
those is it it kind of confirms some of
the things that we think about uh the
programs like this and how we've
designed them
there are a lot of classes that are out
there there are a lot of
um
schools that are out there that you can
learn from vendors
and doing that piecemeal
is inefficient you don't get a broader
understanding of the picture you also
don't have often you know people with
broad experience being able to to help
you learn from what they've learned and
our our point of view for the boot camp
programs that we have like this they are
comprehensive in that
not only are we going to cover what we
believe all the things that you need to
understand including
um uh you know the essentials of of just
Computing you know Basics uh Security
Essentials
um
attacks and and threats and an analysis
and being able to present that analysis
we've gotta you've got to do the full
the full thing and
that doesn't come lightly this is a
six-month program and and the way that
it's structured is it works really well
for
people who are already full-time
employed so there are pre-recorded
videos and learnings and things that you
can do that are on your own
but the the real value is also when you
you come in and you have live sessions
with the instructors and you are
um you're you're interactive you're
going through the things that that uh
they either they wanted to show you but
also you're demonstrating how you grasp
those tools whether it's through a new
script that you wrote does that work
what uh how far do you get uh through
all the gates
um and also having your peers and how
the class is organized into teams
having everybody come together and doing
that and a lot of that work happens also
on the weekends so
um this is a mix of
different modalities
um but it's very participant centered
and you also have access to not only the
platform 24 7 and you can get tech
support uh 24 7 but you have instructors
and Tas
um that you interact with and either can
answer questions or can coach you on the
side whatever your learning preference
really is
um and so it's adaptable like that so
um it is it is comprehensive it is
intensive this is not the easiest cyber
security program
um there will be uh parts of it
especially when you're getting into
understanding
but uh uh Computing Essentials and
understanding how memory works uh you're
going to get into some of the needs
um but we believe that this is a mix
that that's really going to work
for you all
whoops
um
so after the the throughout the program
there are several small projects and
then a Capstone at the very end which is
a larger project that you use to help
demonstrate all the things that you've
learned
um and you can demonstrate and show off
uh code and materials say through GitHub
with potential employers or your sponsor
from your job
um but you're also going to get a
certificate from Caltech at the end of
this there is a letter of of completion
that states the number of continuing
educational credits or units that you
get this program is about 250 hours
you get 26
continuing education units for that
that's a significant amount 250 hours
this is a little long like we said it's
a comprehensive program
um but you also get into a private uh
LinkedIn membership group uh with others
uh that Circle and near the end of the
program if you elect to you can use uh
simply learn and talent inks
career advising services so they'll get
you ready work with you on your resume
work with you on how to best present
um
uh new skills in in coding or
design if you were doing the part of the
web design
um but all these things and really help
get you prepared to
um
to present uh not only your experience
but your new insights and how you both
either defend or think about
vulnerabilities and threats from an
attacker's point of view right
um
there is a online graduation event that
we do with all of our simply learned
programs it occurs about every quarter
um but there are uh boards and
um
and and and times that people talk about
the the value of the program that they
just went through and hear from other
people's experiences and it's really
cool
um
and so one of the things I want to
highlight is also this is a very Project
based course
um it's not
theoretical it's not just read the
slides and and you're good this is a
boot camp that's intensive and geared
around projects and things that you have
to complete so there are assignments
and um
that are either Snippets or
actions that you really have to get
through
um
I think you already know who Caltech is
California Institute of Technology we're
in Pasadena California
uh when we originally started this
program uh we
for those who are in town we wanted to
be able to also take them to the LA
cyber lab
uh in Los Angeles which is and if we can
do that now that uh we're on the back
side of the pandemic
um it is an integrated uh threat
Response Center uh for for the county
and all the different
um
uh major uh
operations centers more rooms uh you
know use this as a central Hub to get
out information about attacks and
threats
um and and so if uh if we can spin that
up again that's going to be that's going
to be great
um
so what do you need to to be a part of
this
um if you've got a background in coding
or at least with python uh that's going
to be great if you're an analytical
thinker that's going to be great if you
don't have that
um
there are some programs that Stuart and
simply learned folks can talk to you
about that can help you know maybe it's
been a while since you've
written a script or something there
there are some uh like many courses and
things that you can do to to best
prepare yourself
um this is a a professional development
program that's geared toward adult
Learners people need to
have finished high school best if you
have
some work experience that you can bring
into this so you understand
the context of how some of this stuff is
happening
um
and
if you've got about five years
experience
three years experience I think that's
fine
um but it really takes somebody who's
super curious
um about uh handling these kinds of
threats and and creating a defensive
posture
for organizations and government
um and and critical infrastructure right
um and if you bring that passion into
this you're going to do really really
well
um so on that question of uh
you know how many years experience do
you have I'm going to stop here let
Stuart
do this poll
we have about 80 people on yeah I
apologize for the clunkiness of the uh
switch off here we'll we'll get that
ironed out for future webinars but uh
right now
um we'll launch the second poll here
all right
leave this open for about
30 seconds
again if you're watching on a streaming
service you can put ABC or D into the
then this question doesn't necessarily
mean just not cyber security experience
but even business experience
um you know how long have you been in
the workforce right
General experience in the workforce
because if you haven't been in cyber
security the program is intended to help
you get into that field
and I'll go ahead and end the poll so
put in your answer in three two one
here we go
so uh our audience today is a very
heavily skewed toward people who are new
in the workforce
um but we do have
some folks who have more than 10 years
of experience so
um great we'll talk about how this
applies to everybody
I'll let you take it back Mike
okay
um
and you should have it
all right uh let's see
um we'll talk a little bit about how we
get ready
um
Stuart talk about this
and the learning environment
right the learning environment is
entirely online
and
the learning management system allows
you to see all of the
courses and modules that make up the
curriculum we'll be sharing that
we've gone to a different screen here um
we'll be sharing that in the next couple
of slides
but um
the core limiting management system lets
you see what you're working on currently
and then when you finish that module it
unlocks your access to the following
module it also gives you access to all
of the necessary
support materials if there are are
videos that the instructor wants you to
watch before class if there's
remedial material you want to take to
brush up on programming skills or that
type of thing all that's available
through the same interface it also
allows you to access the live virtual
classrooms
where you will receive instruction from
the
instructor live you'll be able to
interact with that person
um
take their questions ask them questions
interact with your classmates during the
sessions usually there's uh eight hours
of instruction live each week in either
several two-hour blocks or in two four
hour blocks over the weekend
and then
um
you have the ability to do your tests
your projects all of that in a sandbox
environment
Jupiter lab environment on the
learning management system so you have
you don't need to use your own Computing
Hardware you get access to a virtual
machine that allows you to do any of the
exercises and writing scripts or
programs experimenting with different
um
penetration techniques defense
techniques detection techniques you have
access to all of those tools and
different lab exercises
and when you get through the curriculum
the last module you unlock is your
Capstone project which is something that
you do Under the mentorship of your
instructor
usually takes three to four weeks and it
ties together everything you've learned
during the program into one project that
solves an industry-based problem so
you'd be posed a problem like you were
working for
a big online retailer how would you
defend it against
fraudulent transactions or intrusions
you get to see your progress as you're
going along you get to unlock
certificates for each of the modules
that you complete it also gives you
access to uh
program vouchers or test vouchers rather
for
any particular skills that you may
qualify for along the way that you're
being trained in
so if you're for example taking a module
that qualifies you for comp Tia you
would get a
voucher for that and finally it has all
the support tools that you'll need to
keep on track
it'll give you automatic reminders as
long as you're progressing through your
courses it will give you calendar
reminders for your classes it will allow
you to contact your instructor it'll
give you access to a computer community
bulletin board that lets you
ask questions of other students and
ultimately it gives you access to a 24x7
support network at simply learn which
gives you both
answers to questions about the platform
itself but also answers on the subject
matter so you have that available 24 7.
if you happen to be working at three
o'clock in the morning uh some
coursework and you have a question you
do have some place to turn so
that's the great thing about the
platform it lets you do the work 24x7
basis whenever you have the time to do
it rather than
other than the classes which are
scheduled at particular times everything
else you do on the platform you can do
on your own schedule so that's the
learning environment
thanks George
um and the learning environment uh the
integrated LMS that simply learn has is
one of the reasons why
we partnered with them when we started
our software engineering programs
um it's intuitive
uh you really have all the all the tools
right there
um everything from like you said with
the Jupiter notebooks and uh Python and
all the software that you need
um and the interactivity
um so that's that's really great that's
another thing you don't get in in some
classes
let's see
um
so let's talk about uh the the pieces of
this you're you're going to cover
um starting the the orientation uh of
course but you're really going to start
to get into Computing Essentials
especially if you don't have a
background in this this is going to be
critical so understanding Linux uh
Windows some other systems you
understand operating systems OSI
um how do all these things work how does
how does memory work how do networks
work uh
uh how old devices uh around the
networks
um work not just for security but just
for making things happen right uh you're
going to cover those you're going to get
into more foundations about uh Security
Essentials
um and and paths that uh that people
tend to take
in in the in this full-time program
there is a deep dive into offensive
security uh you'll be red team the other
parts blue team
um we use uh um offensive Securities uh
tool set there's going to be Kali Linux
um you'll spend a lot of time there not
just on the psychology but also uh
actually doing some attacks and trying
to create some
uh whether it's overflows
um Brute Force attempts other attempts
uh you'll use tools that
um
uh the whether it's catalogs of
vulnerabilities that people know
um uh or things for uh uh penetration
testing uh you'll you'll be able to use
that entire Suite of tools you'll spend
a lot more time on the defensive side
um and understanding from the point a
system is is developed how do you design
to make it secure
um if if people are practicing just
security at the end of of compliance
that you're going to miss so many things
so you have to have that understanding
of of start to finish
um how are things going to be
uh defendant and you'll get a chance to
use all of this in the projects in the
Capstone
um
the curricula that
um will share we'll have a lot more
details about that you want to see like
specific tools
but another thing that was just really
great about this is the time that we
actually spend on on offensive security
and
um and the the tool sets of the and the
curricula that that they recommend so
that that's a group that's that if
you're looking for a certification in
that which we highly advise uh it's very
attractive
um you'll you'll be able to use those
tool sets here and and have this to
prepare you for that
um
I've touched on on some of these uh
you'll get more in part of the
curriculum
uh we'll get into different techniques
exploitation pen testing
spoke about most of these
uh I think you're going to be able to
use Splunk
do some log cutting some other forensics
modeling different types of threats
um this guy
this is my colleague Rick uh he's the
executive director for the center uh he
and I put this
uh program together with full stack
Academy which is now a part of Simply
learn
um he uh Donald Robinson who's our chief
cyber security
um in in instructor came out of the
Department of Defense
um uh weighed in on the program we know
it had a head and how it was designed
um
but he's kind of our overall advisor
on this
um one thing we haven't spoken about yet
are uh master classes and one of the
things that we've added in to help
learner outcomes is hearing from other
professionals and just the instructor
the master classes are are Caltech
instructors ctme instructors
that are out of Industry
um that would they can be out of
Academia but for the best part you'll
learn from people in the field who deal
with this stuff uh so we've had people
from Google we've had people from
uh the ports we've had people from other
security organizations uh talked like
once a month on on issues relevant to
what you're learning at that time and so
we'll add that into
the instruction to give you a wider uh
perspective from different areas
um and start uh you want to take us
through these Pages we don't have to
I had it off but um
I'll be glad to do that um
we've seen people coming into the cyber
security program from a number of
different
uh directions
um
people come in from Information
Technology certainly from software but
also from Banking and Financial Health
Care and pretty much every other
sector because cyber security affects
every information system in every
business organization now depends on
Information Systems uh even much more
now than a couple or three years ago or
the pandemic
so um
you have people who come in from
organizations like Microsoft or Amazon
Adobe
um it would be the peers that you'll
have in the classes
among the people who have work
experience
come in who are seconded by their
companies or who are taking this as
Career Development so you
basically have a chance to interact with
people from a broad variety of
backgrounds
and on the next slide we talk about the
career assist service now this is a
program intended for a
U.S or North American audience
um so we offer this to our U.S learners
this is offered in conjunction with
Talent Inc which we'll talk about a
little bit more but you have access to
ongoing
technology
career webinars that we put on you also
have the projects that I mentioned and
we'll see a couple of examples of that
um and then finally
um
the actual job assist Services which are
on the next slide there Mike
yeah and you get access to a talent Inc
proprietary job portal which has a
certain number of job listings that are
exclusive
which is good it's not the most
important part I think of the talenting
partnership the more important parts are
the parts that deal with
um resume rewrite
it turns out today unlike years past
your resume doesn't go in front of a
person until it's been asked by
a automated tracking system and an AI
bot within that system looks for your
match between your resume and the job
description
then it goes to a person if you pass
that filter
so it's really a a kind of art form to
have a resume that number one
uh is compatible with the automated
systems and will easily
run through that filter
and if you're a match get to the other
side
nothing more frustrating than to know
that you have the set of skills that job
description lists but the automated
system doesn't recognize those in your
resumes this solves that problem and
then on the other end of the process the
resume still has to look good when it
sits in front of somebody on their
screen or on their desk
so that they uh see your skills and
highlight your experience so
this process the resume rewrite is very
valuable to you on top of that because
every
job transition whether it's internal or
whether you're looking for a new job for
the first time or whether you're looking
to transfer from one employer to another
you have to go through multiple rounds
of interviews so being able to
do the interview practice sessions being
able to be coached on how to do a
technical interview about your skills
but also on how to do a soft skill or
management type interview on how to be
portray yourself as a team player
and a valuable asset
those are extremely valuable uh parts of
this program as well in being able to do
those one-on-one
preparation sessions and get some career
coaching
um really help you with that so these
Services extend for six months after the
completion when you receive your
certificate you have six months of
remaining time to use these services
of course it's up to you to take
advantage of them
um nobody will schedule them for you but
you can take full use of them and use
them to to leverage your job search
so that's
I think really uh an important part of
this program the next slide we'll talk
about
the webinar series that we do
yeah um
we do a number of informational webinars
we'll be doing more of these later in
this year uh every week we're doing
several webinars and
they bring people from different walks
of Industry to talk about different
subjects whether it's career coaching
whether it's
how to do a job search or whether it's
the latest trends and Technologies uh
particular area so if you you'll see
a short one hour mini classes on cyber
security you'll hear from cyber Security
Experts from time to time who will talk
about uh new trends and about looks for
cyber Security Professionals so that's
available to you these are all free
and
at this point
I'm going to ask this question so again
oh
take back this
privilege here
we launched the third poll
hold on
we'll be back in about a minute here we
go
you should be seeing the poll now
then after this we'll cover people's
questions yeah
and I'm going to retain the house
privilege here Michael Pulaski slides
yeah sure
okay
all right
so about half of our audience is
interested in enrolling in the program
and that's great so we will
share with you how to do that
the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
um
you
submit the application by email to ask
us at simplylearn.net as I mentioned
we're the delivery and administrative
partner for Caltech
we review your qualifications so
according to the Caltech ctme standards
and per the prerequisites that we talked
about before
need to be high school graduate 18 years
or over
you do not have to have programming
experience you do not have to have work
experience but we will take those into
account in your application review on
the main thing you want to know is are
you really committed to learning about
cyber security
um because this is a
program where we want you to commit to
invest the time and the effort to
succeed and will help you along that way
so you'll get a
offer of admission from a learning
consultant and you'll be able to sign up
the next program starts February 12th
with an orientation session on the 10th
of January
the fee for the program is the flat U.S
uh ten thousand dollars
which can be financed that uh
880 a month if you want to put it on
that payment plan
um and as Mike often reminds me uh
employers offered to do often offer
tuition reimbursement that was of course
up to them but you'll want to contact
your employer
and find out if they have a tuition
reimbursement program which will either
pay us directly for the uh for the
course or reimburse you once you
complete it which is the more common way
it's done
um but that's a valuable uh
benefit that you may have from your
employer and you should certainly be
using that
um for more assistance to find out more
about the program uh do contact us at
ask us at simplylearn.net it's not an
obligation to enroll just uh how you
cannot contact us for questions
and we urge everybody to do that whether
you are planning to do this program
soon or whether you're planning to do it
sometime in the future
um and that brings up the next question
which is getting an idea here from
folks from the audience who said they
were interested
when would you be interested in doing it
something you'd like to start in the uh
February class sessions or something
a little bit further down the road
we'll leave this open for another 10
seconds or so
hmm
and I don't see the numbers changing so
I'm going to end it here
and 15 of the folks responded said
they'd like to get into that immediate
February class some folks said they'd
like to do it within three months and
we'll be able to find out the future
session schedules by contacting us at
ask us at simplywin.net so if you're
looking to do this uh later than the
February session please do send us that
email and we will share with you when
the schedules happen
yeah typically we've been running the
cyber security uh program uh
starting a new cohort about every two
months
I think we're going to continue that
um we limit it to about 30 people
so it's not a mooc or you know it's like
you're not in there with 200 people
um so you get a lot of instructor
coverage and the ability to ask
questions and interact with folks so
um if February doesn't work you'll
probably have another one that starts in
April
um
and and like uh some folks have said on
uh on the track it's been in uh in high
demand so
um
so this is our question and answer
period we've got a number of questions
that are in the Q a if you put a
question in the chat it may be easier
for us to see because there's a lot of
traffic on the chat if you would repeat
that question in the Q a box for us
um because that would be uh easier for
us to find it but in the meantime
looking here at some of the questions we
had so
uh Lolita had asked uh do we need to
have prior programming knowledge yeah
and the answer to that of course is
based on the the prerequisite slide is
no you do not have to have prior
programming knowledge
um you'll you'll get the ability to to
gain the coding skills or programming
skills that you need as part of this
program with uh some other basic courses
that you know are available for free and
you'll be able to catch that up for
yourself here yeah coming in with as a
as a system architect and infrastructure
specialist I think you're coming in with
great context and understanding
um analytically how things fit together
uh Lolita so I think you're covered
Walter has a question you talked about
um
is experiencing 15 years of experience
as a compliance professional and
so if you're you've been working for 15
years in a certain aspect of cyber
security this is an opportunity Walter
to
broaden your your toolkit and your your
scope of skills so that you can look at
other
aspects of cyber security and maybe move
into other career paths and grow your
career faster
you know I'd expand on on that that you
know compliance whether you're doing
like PCI compliance or sock compliance
or ISO compliance
um all those things that like story said
you're that that gives you a really good
background into
some of the aspects uh for
understanding not just business
processes but technical processes
Financial processes
um and understanding where
vulnerability is live within those
yeah I think those will work well
um we had an anonymous
question
about whether you choose the Capstone
project yourself and the answer to that
is that the Capstone projects you choose
from a menu of several different
projects from different
Industries so that you can
choose one that appeals to you based on
which industry it's addressing these are
problems that are based on real world
situations that companies have to face
so
um we do have to restrict it to to not
be
completely up to you because we we have
to have a uniform grading system for
that final project
um
but the you have uh some level of choice
um
what do you learn about the anonymous
question here also from uh
what do I learn about
after the introduction to security
ethical hacking what next after this so
I think we
did mention a bit on the on the
detailed aspects of the course
you learn first the fundamentals but
then you go into both the red team side
and then the blue team side the red team
side being
thinking like a hacker looking at
different ways to exploit
vulnerabilities to systems
um
and
doing things like penetration exercises
so that you look for
um how to exploit vulnerabilities of
systems
from that side and then you go into the
blue team module the final module before
the Capstone which is
looking at it from the defender side
how do you detect intrusions how do you
deal with it
kinds of cases what you do to
improve the defense of your system how
do you test
your system from a white hat kind of
point of view and
those different skills are all based on
Hands-On projects and Labs so you're
going to be doing work
on the systems with the different tools
available to you and
gaining that experience you'll be able
to document and show to potential future
employers
uh question about why is it hard to see
entry-level jobs in cyber security
an interesting question tell me more
about what what that is yeah we'd like
that person to to um
uh elaborate on that because there are
quite a lot of entry-level jobs in cyber
security it's a mentioned it's a growing
field because
uh even compared to just a few years ago
so many more
um
systems businesses are using
computer systems Data Systems from
online systems remote systems even down
to the level of going into a local
restaurant
see that little QR code on the table
that
lets you access the menu
you have the QR code on the table to let
you access the menu it usually lets you
access payment as well which means it's
a point of vulnerability for somebody
service provider that Services the
restaurant or whether it's the
restaurant itself
this is the place where cyber security
attack could be launched from and if you
went to the restaurant business because
you're really great at making food and
serving customers you probably never
thought about the need to protect your
business from cyber security
but now that you have digital payment
systems and online ordering and all the
other things like that
Now You're vulnerable
um so
there's lots of demand for people in
this field who can help protect against
Bad actors and then
that leads to a lot of entry-level jobs
I think we had a comment
chat about
um
the kinds of
salaries that are available to people
and you'll be able to see that on any of
the job boards like indeed or Glassdoor
dice everything do a search you should
be able to find
uh entry-level jobs
um it's always the challenge in any
field when you're
um
when you don't have
actual work experience but one of the
things about this program is it gives
you practical experience that you can
demonstrate to the person you're
interviewing with and you can say here
is the the Capstone project
this is how I solved this problem so
they can use that as a demonstration of
your experience for an entry-level job
um what about those of us not in the U.S
how do we get access to the talent
service so for people who are in this
program is designed for people who are
in the United States
um Caltech offers other programs through
simply learn that are available
worldwide
um but right now we only have the career
assist servants for service for people
in the United States or India if you're
in one of the programs where we offered
India we do have a partnership there
with IIM jobs
um uh we are working on expanding this
to other
geographic regions because we do operate
worldwide but um right now it's only
available
in the U.S
for this particular program
then the live hours are
uh Pacific time than us friendly so
if if you are coming in from outside
North America
um
or South America it could be a challenge
to do this yeah
what is the live session schedule Mike
what are the typical
session you know class schedules for
them yeah the the session if we're
following the same pattern uh would
probably be eight to twelve on Saturday
and Sunday
um and so that's a significant amount of
of time on the weekends and you have to
commit to doing those yes there are
videos that are provided
um
later if you need to catch up but you
really need to be a part of the
interactive sessions
um and all the other content is
available on demand and so it's as as
you fit it during the week I mean
overall
we're trying to estimate you know people
spend about uh 10 hours a week uh some
people spend 15 some people spend five
it depends on your experience
um
and
you know it's hopefully it works well
for people who are full-time employed
um but the weekend uh
you know eight hours on the weekend uh
is sometimes a show stopper for people
and we understand that that's okay
but this is what this particular program
calls for
a comment on that as well as a is that
you know you understand that
there are things that happen during
people's lives like vacations and other
things that will call for them to be
away on a weekend
um the sessions are recorded So if you
miss one or two you can catch up
but the intention is and the requirement
of the program is that you have to
attend a certain percentage of the live
sessions directly so that you can't
simply rely on the fact that oh I'll
just uh watch the recorded versions and
do the program that way
uh not how the program works and that's
not how you can succeed really well in
the program
um the
design of that and the reasons for those
requirements is that we want you to end
up with a successful uh experience with
a certificate with the Capstone project
that you can be proud of and show off
and that really requires both the
attendance that the majority of the live
sessions and it requires the dedication
of the work in between we got a question
here from
uh the users BBC Barrios which is how
much time investment is needed when you
watch models videos
um
however what the weekly requirement and
we we tell people you should budget 10
to 15 hours a week for that kind of work
um
because that's
really is what it takes you do have to
do homework projects labs
you have to watch videos
to if you're coming in without the
programming background you'll have to
watch a few extra ones in order to get
um
some of them
foundational
work done
so you do need to expect and commit to
15 to 10 to 15 hours a week
um so it's not
it's not something that you can do
completely casually but you can do it on
your own schedule which is
good this is a six month program a
Christian asked a question how long the
program will take
and
um
so Mike you might want to answer this
anonymous question I've just started my
journey on cyber security what things do
I need to start with
um
so elaborate more on you just started
your journey in cyber security do you
mean it
in this information session
um you know really the the things you
need to be able to to start with and
you'll get that through the orientation
with simply learn but
there are some presentations about
um so Ed either like had a break into
cyber security for a career there are
other assets that are out there I think
that that can be shared understanding
uh you know there's a lot of good free
content that's out there
um and you should consume all of it on
the find stuff that's created by
reputable people and and others
um yeah just
start start learning
um
and yeah
Mike talked about much of this in
describing the foundational course
um the foundational module of this
course so you know I'll be sharing a
link to the recording of this session
you'll be able to go back and take a
look at some of that but the the notion
is that
um there are certain basic concepts of
cyber security you need to be familiar
with and as you get familiar with those
you'll you'll start think you know
thinking about which ones interest you
most and which ones you want to look
deeper into the great thing about this
program of course is it gives you a
broad
uh Foundation across many different
aspects of cyber security so that uh not
only can you go deeper into the ones
that interest you but you have the
knowledge of the rest of it so that you
understand how
your particular area of focus relates to
and draws upon those other areas as well
uh the lecture schedule live lecture
schedule I think I just answered that
it's actually eight to twelve Saturday
8-12
Sunday on
morning time is the
U.S Pacific time zone
lalitha asks another question if I'm
located in Canada is this available
uh and yes the answer is yes you can
take this course from Canada you can
take a course from
any Court country in North or South
America you can technically enroll in it
from anywhere in the world
um but again the career assist part is
specific to the US the rest of it is
God
um
somebody asked what a person with a
cissp certificate is called and
I was going to give a flip answers to it
I was going to say they're qualified
that's what they're called qualified or
a certificate holder but according to
the according to the initials it's a
certified information system security
professional yeah
um
which is good and but you can also
uh
uh other certificates can cover
different areas so a lot of the CompTIA
um whether you know starting off with
Security Plus than doing some of the
others uh they
there's a huge number of certifications
that that they have that that you should
explore what's right for you in the
specialty that you want to do
um but then probably the best is also to
have the offensive security
um
OS CIP I forget right now uh but that's
a great certification so certification
is different from certificate Caltech
provides an academic certificate uh and
and tied to continuing education units
which is what employers need often to um
to validate for paying tuition so they
know that you've learned
uh something from a 260 hour program
um and then the certifications uh or
through either agencies and
and
um professional societies
that are exam based
um
and so we'll provide vouchers uh for
some of those
um but you don't do those certifications
within this program just a
um just to be clear
um how many years of experience does a
newbie need to be to get before getting
a job in cyber security field so the
intention of this program is that after
six months in this program with
successful completion
that you will be qualified for an
entry-level job in cyber security
um again because it's a growing field
there's a lot of demand for for people
and there's a lot of willingness to take
on people
you'll have the advantage over somebody
who's a
quote unquote complete newbie because
you will have
the hands-on experience and the
the project
uh portfolio that you can show off to
people that will give them the
confidence that you know what you're
talking about and know how to do the
things you say you can do
um again the question about
um
confidence and motivation on your
journey in the cyber security field I
think that the best motivation is
if you take a look at uh
any of the job boards and you look at
there about section on different career
areas and they'll tell you
uh what the Outlook is for cyber
security jobs and you'll be able to take
a look at the range of salaries that are
available from the entry level and up
and that should give you a good
understanding or good impression of why
this is a great field to get into
the future potential for your career
would be
so that's really the best place to look
there's a little bit about that on our
course page on our website
right now put a link to that into our
chat here
so I will I can I'm allowed to
I'll just you know make a comment on on
the motivation piece that everybody has
different things that motivate them
um and
one of the things I like about when
we're pulling in people to talk in the
in the program over the last couple
years
um I get inspired by
those folks
um
and and
hearing stories about the either the
things that have happened
um you know whether it's takedowns or
just the business disruption
um and and those things motivate me and
and I know that they motivate others in
our program that you know you're also
there for a higher purpose you're there
to defend people who you know they've
they've given up into their data or from
finances to the bank we want to be able
to help them keep their transactions and
their privacy secure
um
you see takedowns of
um
electric plants and things like that and
people don't have don't have power
um you have other Bad actors who
attacked their uh other things such as
airports or power generation
um and it's it's helping people and it's
helping the businesses and it's helping
cities municipalities
or even in National Security so whatever
uh calling appeals to you
um you can dial into that that that that
motivates a lot of people in finding
kind of their purpose through their
security
yeah I mean
cyber security attacks
generally irritate people but some of
them are
downright despicable in terms of as you
mentioned Mike you know shutting down
oil pipelines on the East Coast shutting
down power grids there's an attack on a
hospital in Germany which required
people to to
not get the treatment yeah so and and
then of course breaches of uh personal
information all of which there are a
number of people out there who really
feel that this is a way to
to be the good guy in a ongoing battle
so
that may be one of the motivations for
you
um and I think our last question here uh
yeah I was going to put in chat but
um
for some reason it won't let me like
send a chat out to everybody yeah
because you're not the host
unfortunately okay so
um for other motivation and
understanding the field uh I highly
recommend going to the cesa website and
that's
cisa.gov so that's the center for
infrastructure or cyber infrastructure
Security Agency
um there are a lot of good uh uh points
of reference on there uh for all the
different kinds of whether it's cyber
security or critical infrastructure
um
understand what's kind of happening and
also uh for careers so make sure that
you guys check out sisa.gov
yep and
again with the last question here is uh
about which of the different you know
industry certifications
are a good start I think
you can start with almost any of them
and then move into the ones you know
there are some that are more broad-based
and basic which you would use the
starting point and then you'd move into
advanced and specialized certifications
but um really
this program is a good way to get
a foundation that lets you then build on
um and the last comment I just want to
share is uh from user CBC Barrios again
um says I can do 10 to 15 hours a week
but I can't do 60 hours a week and
that's really the reason why we designed
this program
because a traditional Boot Camp style
program
requires people to travel somewhere sit
in a
conference room a bunch of other people
for 40 or more hours a week
for weeks on end to
absorb all that material supposedly in a
very short time and very intensive way
well this program allows you to do it
with less of a time commitment but just
as intensive in terms of your
interaction with instructors your
interaction with the material and it's
something that you don't have to travel
to you can do it from wherever you are
you can watch some of the pre-recorded
video materials on your smart device
while you're traveling or commuting so
you can do um
this program much more easily much more
flexibly and yet
at least as good if not much better
um retention of the material because
you're retaining it at a more
uh human Pace rather than a artificially
induced
high pressure pace so with that I'm
going to um
go on to the last
couple of elements of our presentation
we have one last Poll for people who are
interested
in this program
one more question or did you freeze
sorry about that it uh
kicked me out for a second
oh
so last poll
and this is just to
ask whether you wanna
talk to one of our learning Consultants
so if you're ready to enroll you can
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
but if you're not ready to enrolled but
you're interested in the program
please do
email us at that address again
I have about uh
quarter of our audience is interested in
getting information and support with
that so again if you're not ready to
enroll yet
okay hold on a second
also the question said had maybe on the
screen but I didn't have it online not
not in the poll oh sorry about that um
I was going to show you the last slide
but basically it's a thank you slide so
I'm not going to show that to you
um but I want to thank everybody again I
will put into the chat window one more
time
the uh
link to the program page and email
address
just so you have it and we will be
sending you a follow-up email with
the recording link watch this
presentation again at your leisure to
catch any parts that you missed
um
and we hope that we can welcome you into
the Caltech learning community
We Stand ready to do
anything you need to answer your final
questions
um
and get you enrolled
so thank you all for being here thank
you Mike very much for sharing your time
and your expertise
yeah thanks for it
um
everybody have a great year and thank
you for tuning in
okay Happy New Year and we'll see you
hopefully uh in the course later on this
year so thank you very much